so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
see
[Music]
today
[Music]
r
[Music]
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
for the alliance
[Applause]
[Music]
for azeroth
hi everyone i'm john heit general
manager for warcraft and with me today
are my friends ian hausacostas who is
the game director for world of warcraft
and holly longdale who leads up the
production team for wow classic
i really appreciate you tuning in i know
we're really excited to be able to give
you updates on what's happening in world
of warcraft but first i want to thank
our community for all the feedback
you've given us this year and especially
our community council you've helped
shape and influence the updates that
we've done recently and what you're
going to see in the upcoming year i mean
really for shadowlands in particular the
story of the last nine months or so of
this expansion is all about the
community and it's shaped by what we've
been hearing from them
and us realizing as a team that we just
collectively needed to do a better job
of making sure the community felt heard
and so that led us to the changes we
made in 915 but also really re-examining
some of the assumptions and foundations
of world of warcraft about things like
character investment and mains versus
alts or how catch-up should work or the
appropriate role of friction in our
systems
and i think 915 represented a step in
the direction of letting players have
more freedom to play world of warcraft
the way they want to play it and we
really built our eternities and content
update from the ground up around those
principles what are some of the things
that the community said that influenced
your decisions for attorneys in things
like the method and pacing of
acquisition of the covenant legendary
item tons of tuning and i think every
step of the way um we were listening to
make sure that we were carrying forward
those lessons learned in the course of
915
into eternity's end and beyond so
wow classic was really
came about because of the community yeah
they continue to help guide and support
us as classic evolves world of warcraft
has always been about the world and the
players that inhabit it
and we are in a lot of ways curators and
caretakers of that journey and of that
experience and so once this classic
community formed
and grew
we had to listen to them it's this tide
of listening to the community and paying
attention to what is a good experience
for our players now
and where we really saw a sea change in
this idea is with our season of mastery
realm which is a season of fresh start
classic and initially we were talking
about it like it was going to be like a
fresh start let's try this experiment in
a season it'll be about a year long and
then when the community found out about
it we started seeing this upswell yeah
the team just took that idea and ran
with it and turned you know what started
out as a small community project
into this soul of iron system that
became a centerpiece of season of
mastery in a whole new opt-in hardcore
mode that we've seen communities built
around
lots of you know
thrilling victory and painful defeat
five hours i mean
yeah and it continues like burning
crusade classic we wanted to balance the
paladin seals between horde and alliance
so we made an addition there we wouldn't
have gotten there without the
community's input
so
influence the community you've got
another update and
pretty significant controversial change
for this yeah cross-faction play uh
coming coming in nine two five uh which
is on a public test realm now uh it's a
big secret crowd faction
you're breaking with a 17-year tradition
yeah it's something it was not an easily
made decision by any means you know and
i think this is another one of those
areas where really
we
try to take to heart community feedback
and requests and ask ourselves as a team
whether there's a way to accommodate
such an earnestly held desire and still
feel like we're being true to the to the
roots of the game i think players desire
to play with their friends who might
prefer a different faction or to play
with the faction that they more closely
identify with even though their ray
group is elsewhere it's really important
for me i play a lot of alts and i love
absorbing the story for each race and
having that ability to play with all of
my friends across factions is fantastic
at the end of the day
the battle cry is for the horde it's not
against the alliance it's not death to
the alliance it's about pride in one's
faction and i think there's a way to
preserve that and even strengthen that
while giving players the ability to make
the same choice we've seen the greatest
heroes make time and time again i can't
wait to do this i'm seeing a lot of my
friends that i never knew had a max
level character in the other faction
suddenly come out of the woodwork and
then you know with these these
cross-faction groups many of them are
going to be diving into something new
that we're doing to kind of cap off
shadowlands a season four uh kind of a
remix a little bit a bit of a greatest
hits revisiting our all of our raid
zones across the expansion bringing in
some
familiar older favorites into the mythic
plus rotation and you know we recognize
this is kind of a closing chapter a
little bit of a send-off to shadowlands
as everyone gets ready for what happens
next what will come next want to give
you know a fun new challenge for
everyone to sink their teeth into really
cool stuff for for modern wow players
i'm super excited about the gear
upgrades you're going to give me and the
chance to go back and play some of those
those awesome raids there's a lot to
explore very exciting for our next
adventure in world of warcraft
we're going to go back to azeroth
we're going to a space with high fantasy
i mean our fans have asked for this for
a long time this has been kind of the
foundation of much of the lore of wow
so without further ado let's watch the
cinematic
[Music]
the world has been sundered
it cries out in pain
we must go to its aid
we entrust our ancestral home to you
the watchers
you will feel our return
in the waking of the land
then
you must light the beacon of tear hold
lest the path home be lost to us forever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the world is healing
but her fate is yet uncertain
[Music]
together
we shall be azeroth's protectors once
again here
the new age of dragons shall begin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dragons dragons this is so cool no one
saw it coming no inside coming carefully
kept secret but seriously i mean
what did we just see there
the awakening of the dragon isles the
return of dragons the dawn of a new age
right we've seen wrathion searching for
his father's legacy searching for the
dragon isles there's a reason why he
hasn't been able to find them until now
the beacon going off is that summoning
the dragons it is removing the
concealment that had hidden the dragon
isles from the world but also beckoning
the dragons back urgently
in a time of need i assume
pretty good variety of locales within
the dragon isles yes the dragon isles as
have standard for wow expansion consist
of five zones four standard leveling
zones and a new starter zone that we'll
get to in a second can you talk a little
bit about how the team found ways to
thread the dragon aspects throughout the
environments the the dragon isles are a
place that is lush and primal bursting
with elemental energy as azeroth herself
reawakens those primal forces are
expressed throughout the environment
whether it's magma activity volcanic
activity whether it's the icy wastes of
the azure span and each one of those has
a connection to a dragonflight that
we've seen before and it's going to be
an amazing place for players to arrive
at and explore all right you know i'm
going to ask yes okay so
can i be a dragon let's
start getting into some features here
and what dragon flight means for you as
well as just a place um so first off yes
we have an all all-new playable race the
drac theater race yeah
this is a draconid draconic race but
dragons in warcraft have the ability to
take on a humanoid form
what classes can they be they have
unique abilities as literally a dragon
that doesn't quite fit any of our
existing classes and so what we're doing
is this is not just a new race but it's
also a new class you know adding a new
race to world of warcraft and not just
an allied array so something that we
don't do lightly but telling this
expansion this story so focused around
dragons felt like the perfect time for
it so if you were a drac theater you
will be the evoker class drag there can
only be evokers evokers could only be
dracuter and the reason why only a
dracula could be an evoker is that an
evoker is really combining
the ability to call upon the magic of
the different aspects with the unique
physical gifts that a drak thier has the
ability to actually take flight and do
an enyxia style strafing deep breath
over the battlefield land on the other
side
knock everyone back with a wing buffet
and then unleash your magical abilities
yes please
the evoker has two specializations
they're a hybrid of either range dps or
healer and they wear male armor we
figured you know with the new hero
classes classes we've added over the
years we have enough melee we don't need
more of those
and also probably don't need any more
any more leather wearers the raid
leaders are going to love you for that
exactly this is definitely a hero class
and so that means that you know like the
death knights before them or demon
hunters they will be starting level 58
and then they're going to have a new
starter zone so they're going to have a
slightly different journey into the
dragon isles as opposed to the rest of
us that are sailing there from other
parts of azeroth
can you talk a little bit about the
customizations like what
is going to be able to identify my
director character basically anything
and everything you know skin color hair
color jewelry tattoos other adornments
you can make this character the
expression of your identity in azeroth
new zone
new class yep erase tell us about some
of the the system updates yeah futures
of course the new expansion brings with
it you know new systems new features i
think in recent expansions one of the
things we've tended to do is really have
these deep features that were closely
tied to a specific expansion that would
then get left behind as we moved on
and we've heard loud and clear from
players that you know it's kind of a
bummer to start off every new expansion
by leaving a large part of your
character behind by leaving a large part
of your progression behind so this time
around what we're doing is really
pouring all of our energy
into permanent revamps overhauls and
improvements to world of warcraft's core
systems things like our progression
systems this case our talent system is
something that we want to completely
revamp we want to take a look at our ui
we want to take a look at professions so
with the talent revamp and the arrival
of classic did you learn anything about
how our talents work i think seeing a
new generation of players play with
those talents and work through those
talent trees really underscored some of
the things that frankly we lost when we
shifted to the mists of pandaria style
talents and beyond a big piece of that
was some just the granularity the
feeling of getting a level and spending
a point to customize your character to
make yourself a bit better in some
specific way
but also you know that sense of
hybridity that you could have that's
something that we've largely lost and so
the new talent system avoids directly
pitting
player power throughput choices directly
against those sort of utility hybrid
choices because we know that there's
always a right outcome there and we also
understand that you know there's a lot
of strength in the flexibility of the
modern talent system to let players
customize their talents for a particular
encounter or four dungeons versus pvp
and we don't want to lose any of that so
john ui oh my god
yes i got this 30 inch monitor trying to
keep track of where i am on the map all
my buffs and oh over here what's going
on in chat it has literally made my eyes
go like this
and you're not alone in that we've made
a lot of incremental changes and
additions over the years but really this
is a revamp this is an overhaul and so
we're excited to really modernize the
look and feel while staying true to the
origins of world of warcraft you know at
the same time we're not looking to take
away the sort of power user
customization there add-ons are still
there if you want them but we want a
much better default out-of-the-box
experience for all players new and old
alike i think can i reduce elements
remove elements if i want to explore the
world and see the beauty of azeroth when
it comes to specific elements as much as
possible we want to let players choose
what to show and what to hide so that
they can control it themselves you
mentioned professions
i have a critical question about this go
on
can i wear a chef's hat yeah i knew it
our approach to professions in dragon
flight is really all about delivering on
fantasy and identity as a crafter and so
if you want to be a serious blacksmith
if you want to be a great leather worker
we want to deliver the ability to invest
time and energy into that become a
master crafter be able to make items
that are in demand interact with the
community one of the big pieces that we
want to do to support that is a new work
order system to have a bit more
convenience than just spamming trade
chat all day but if you or someone
you're not yourself a blacksmith but you
have a bunch of mats and you want them
forged into a great sword
you can put that work order up list your
mats offer a commission and a skilled
blacksmith can come along and make you
the weapon of your dreams i think we
left out one thing though
be a drag there go to dragon isles can i
have a dragon what's the fantasy of
dragons if not soaring over the lands
and so we're really excited to introduce
a feature that we're calling dragon
riding it's dynamic with you know
everything from momentum to dive bombs
the ability to you know just sort of
build that speed up and feel the world
rushing past you in a way that should be
much more exciting than traditional
flight that we've had it made available
in the past but that's also available
for players through a customizable
dragon mount right from the start
so this is a skill you learn over time
right to become an awesome dragon rider
yes you'll be able to sort of upgrade
aspects of your flight but you will have
this new form of flight from the start
and the dragon companion that you have
is of course very thoroughly
customizable which is a new a new thing
for us for mounts this is not just a
generic dragon that everyone has but a
drake that is yours you know what do you
want it scales to look like horns the
shape of its head other attachments
armor pieces and more take your pick
this is so cool
so yes the dragonflight expansion is
going to see players leveling to 70
going to the all-new continent of the
dragon isles which consists of five
zones four standard leveling zones and a
new starter zone for our drakthir class
as well as a range of systems revamps
such as a new talent system an overhaul
an update to our ui and an entirely
fresh look at professions with more
depth than ever before
also getting around the dragon isles is
going to come in the form of dragon
riding which lets you customize and
upgrade your own mount so that you can
fly in a sense from the start and of
course as with any new expansion we have
a new set of dungeons a raid and much
more to come we also have an alpha that
will be starting up in in the future
check out our website for more
information and keep an eye out for
those opt-in signups if you want to help
us test out dragonflight and give us
even more feedback to make it better we
do have a deep dive that follows this so
please stay around
classic players we haven't forgotten
about you you could probably guess where
we're gonna go next one of the all-time
favorite expansions from world of
warcraft let's watch the cinematic
we had forgotten
did you think
is
[Music]
my son the day you were born
the very forests of lordaeron whispered
the name
arthas
when my days have come to an end
you
shall be
king
[Music]
it's just incredible isn't it every time
i see the cinematic i get chills no pun
intended i do i get chills as you saw
wrath of the lich king classic is coming
this year it brings back so many
memories when you see that cinematic
what do you remember from wrath of the
lich king anytime you want to talk about
undead frozen dragons how can you not go
back to sindragosa as the source that
was the first expansion i played with my
youngest son so i can remember on that
platform black goo and you know chunks
of ice falling off and having to repeat
that battle with the lich king but we
finally downed him it was such an
incredible moment he jumped up out of
his room and i jumped up out of my
office
so it's a very lasting tale for me
so as you know with this expansion you
will in pre-patch be able to play the
death knight they will start at level 55
you don't have to have a high level
character to make a death knight so
everyone will be able to make one we're
excited to give players some time before
wrath officially launches to get geared
up and ready to jump in to northrun with
everybody else and there are so many
zones and areas to explore in northrend
and i want us to talk about some of our
favorites so for me grizzly hills has a
very special place in my heart the music
was some of the best i've experienced in
world of warcraft i still make my way
all the way up to storm peaks to try and
find the time loss proto-drake and have
yet to get it i've got to say dragon
blight the wide open nature of the zone
warmer s temple in the center of it it's
an unforgettable expansion as both a
developer and a player and kind of
making that transition from one to the
other now let's talk about some changes
so one thing we looked at is dungeon
finder and it feels like how we envision
classic dungeon finder is not a good fit
for our community that was kind of the
first step that may have eroded some of
that social fabric now as people have
gone through the experience of going
back to vanilla rebuilding those groups
relying on each other
not wanting necessarily a random
participant just to show up and then
leave yep yeah that makes total sense
but today you can do that in shadowlands
you'll be able to do that in
dragonflight it's a self-selected group
of people who specifically want that
different experience yes let's make sure
that's what we continue to give them
that leads right into
arena teams in marine crusade classic so
we'd listen to the community and we'd
remove that because individual raiding
is
preferable a better experience for them
than arena teams also with wrath of the
lich king barbershop which allows you to
customize your character we're going to
be adding a few more options that were
not existing when wrath launched but
also there's another side of this where
we are not going to charge a real money
fee it was a paid character
customization fee right yeah it seems
the right thing to do that that just be
available in game for gold and we add
more options to it right it's sort of
like spell batching in a sense there's a
lot of technical advancements and it's
not about the philosophy of what makes
classic classic what brings people
together it's just what's the better
experience
and let's not artificially restrict
something that we can provide a better
version of just for the sake of
nostalgia and this is we're happy to say
this is one of those cases so rath the
level caps being increased to level 80
so we'll be introducing a level 70 boost
so that players who want to get in with
their friends or just explore northrend
right away will be able to do that you
can't apply it to a death knight but you
will be able to use it otherwise and of
course we have inscription a whole new
profession so we're really excited about
that yeah and as we continue this road
to wrath we're going to be looking to
getting a lot more feedback on beta and
we'll make changes as we need to
such an exciting time to be playing
world of warcraft we have the return of
the wrath of lich king for classic fans
and
taking us somewhere new with dragonfly
we're so excited to be able to bring
these adventures to you don't forget
there's a deep dive on dragonflight
where you're going to get a lot more
information thank you so much for
spending this time with us and we'll see
you in azeroth and we'll see you in
northrend
and in the dragon isles
[Music]
hi there welcome to the dragon flight
deep dive i'm steve denuzer and i'm
taryn gregory starting it off here we're
going to talk about the setting and the
story of dragonflight we've got this
great expansion uh exciting pre-render
trailer that everyone just watched so
let's talk about the setting for
dragonflight the dragon isles dragon
isles have been
known for a long time in warcraft
history as a mysterious place where the
dragons came from long ago but we never
knew much more than that we're going to
this place that is kind of the brood
lands of all the dragon flights the
place where they nested where they built
their civilization the dragon isles was
the center of the dragon's kingdom when
the world was young and the mortal races
were just starting to form kingdoms of
their own but when the legion invaded
for that war of the ancients that
sundering that resulted from the the
explosion of the well of eternity
literal world literal sundering of the
continents of azeroth and because of the
breaking of the world that magic kind of
drained away and the land went dormant
so they had to leave the dragon isles
behind and as we saw in the pre-render
they left behind some titan watchers to
look over the land and when
someday they hoped that elemental energy
would resurge once again and draw the
dragons home reestablish their kingdom
and that's when the message goes out to
the flights and they feel it in their
bones now it's the time for the sky to
light up with the colors of the aspects
once again and for alex strazza and the
others to come home but the land has
changed a lot in all these thousands of
years they've been away and some very
old threats have awakened as well we're
looking into the culture of dragons as
they exist in warcraft dragons as we
know them today were very different in
the early past the early history of
azeroth they were much more primitive
much more savage what we now know as
proto-dragons and then some of the
dragons were empowered to become the
aspects the green flight red flight blue
flight bronze flight black flight each
with unique powers each with the ability
to protect the world in different ways
these pillars of draconic power
appointed to defend azeroth from threats
within and without dragons used that
power both for good in the case of most
of the aspects but also for nefarious
reasons in the case of the black dragon
flight led by nilfarian who would become
deathwing and what we will find in
dragonfly is that some of these ancient
divisions run deep and so it begs the
question where do we go from here if
this is an opportunity to reclaim their
legacy to be the protectors as the
cinematic mentioned that they once were
to do that they're going to need the
help of our heroes our players to come
to the dragon isles with them and face
some of these reawakening challenges
because it's not just that this land is
peacefully waiting for the dragons to
return and reclaim it there's those old
enemies that have awakened as well yeah
one of those being a race of kind of
elemental half giants the jared the
dragon isles isn't just populated by
dragons or just by the jared and there's
also many other occupants here in the
dragons i've been here either just
recently or for a while including a fan
favorite coming back the tuskar that's
going to be awesome we've got other
cultures there as well in the dragon
isles we're going to find out about a
civilization of centaurs that predates
the ones that arose on calum dormant
later and some of our favorite
characters that we've seen over the last
few expansions such as wrathion and
whether he's ready to step up into a
leadership role or if there are other
alternatives out there that would be
better suited to the job of being the
aspect of the black dragonfly
i think one thing the
players are going to be really excited
about this expansion is the new playable
race the drak fear that's right and this
is something that neltharion before he
was deathwing before he went full crazy
world dragon that he put into motion
miltharian saw those primalists that
were kind of breaking away from the
aspects and what they wanted and so in
those first experiments he took the
essence of dragons their strength their
nobility their wisdom and he combined it
with that scrappiness that that
adaptability that the mortal race has
had and he wanted to use that to create
the ideal soldier in his mind the drac
theater
exploration is really one of the key
themes of this expansion you're we're
going to be going to this ancient place
that the dragons left behind long ago so
we've made these huge zones with all
kinds of places to delve into and find
little treasures and little secrets
tucked away it's gonna be a lot of fun
for players to be exploring these
landscapes and there's so much
architectural history and how clearly
aspirational was the kingdom of the
dragons and how
it lost so much and the themes of trying
to return to that to try to find your
legacy
to try to figure out who you were before
everything went awry
but there's questions you know thematic
questions of
what does it mean to be true to your
legacy are we going to repeat the
mistakes of the past the dragons have
had to learn those lessons just like the
mortal kingdoms have had to and i think
that's one of the reasons why the
dragons see this now as the time that
they have to return and they have to
step up once again as protectors of
azeroth we're helping the dragons
because the dragons have helped us in
the past too so by using the explorers
league and the reliquary together that
allows us to delve into some of that
history and when i look you know upon
the dragon isles and all of its visual
splendor i get so excited for the
prospect of a truly azerothian adventure
alongside calicos along with wrathian
ebenhorn
with isera's daughter marithra as each
one of them is trying to find their own
flights
i am taken
by the exploration and the potential for
adventure and just new horizons within
this world there's going to be old
stories from that time past that history
that only the dragons knew for the
longest time we're going to be able to
explore that it really feels like just a
breath of fresh air so now we're going
to turn things over to some of our
colleagues who will take you on that
deep dive into the locations and the
features of dragonflight
hello i'm stephanie i'm josh i'm jackie
and i'm gary and we're part of the teams
that are building the first two zones
the encounter in the dragon isles the
waking shore and the onaran plains
the very first zone in dragonfly you're
going to come to is the waking shores
it's wild untamed land it's waking up
around you too and the elements are just
going crazy the art team again has hit
it out of the park you'll see like a
lava mountain flowing in through the
beach giant proto dragon swooping down
gobbling up members of your expedition
we have such rife opportunities to show
elementals rising up because of the
crazy magic that's flying around
the one thing i love is just how you get
to the dragon isles right so you're
going to get on your boat and storm
window orgrimmar and the first thing you
do is sail between like the dragon ruin
architectures the boats come right
alongside each other you can jump from
one boat to the other and just start
causing havoc on the other faction's
boat for those who love pvp this is a
great opportunity for war mode it's free
for all out there it's gonna be great
but it's okay there's an innkeeper on
the beach so that if you're in that
situation you don't want to be in war
mode anymore you can just hop out right
there the reliquary and the explorers
league are working together the horton
alliance are sending an expedition
together it's not the military it's not
the soldiers this is the scientists the
settlers exploring this new land so it's
a lot more optimistic tone one of my
favorite things about the waking shores
is the red dragonflight led by queen
alextraza the lifebinder they have the
mandate of nurturing and protecting all
life which means horton alliance
gore locks
trolls everybody so they take that duty
seriously when the port and the lions
come to the waking shores they want to
be there to help guide the people
through the new land and welcome them
but they're not the only one in the
waking chores
we have the ancestral home of the black
dragon flight there too which has fallen
on tough times since deathwing's descent
and so wrathion's coming over to the
isles with us and he's gonna try and
come to terms with the state of the
dragon flight which is a few loyal
draconids and dragon spawn trying to
hold their ground what can the future of
the dragonfly be if it's just wrathion
because it's not just the dragons that
are coming back to the dragon house but
also their long time rival the jardin i
love the jardin so much they're half
giants that wield the power of magma and
when the waking shores and the
dragonalls went to slumber they also
slumbered they're back now and they are
ready to raise chaos yeah they're
massive they're riding giant lava
mammoths parading around just stomping
on your face and they were the enemies
of the dragonfly for so long they fought
against the red dragonflight hunted
dragons down and they're really taking
this opportunity to rise up as the red
dragonflight have the mandate of
nurturing life they don't want to just
stomp out the jardin completely but they
want to make sure that they don't have
the power to affect those around them
negatively to make sure they don't go on
a rampage and destroy the ecosystem that
has been created here and so those are
awesome things in the waking shore but
steph there really is only one right
answer for the best thing in waking
shores right what this is true
ducks
they finally have those webbed feet
hooligans in our game we crack the
technology
figure it out they can fly you should be
proud thank you
it's gonna be awesome the unarmed planes
come right after the waking shores
it's so breathtaking at first glance the
onaron planes are big wide open planes
and the player is going to be
constricted a little bit and then you
see this big contrast of his own we
don't always get that opportunity that
cinematic moment where the player can
have a framed view when they see this
area come out and you got that postcard
shot of the planes
and then you see this giant fire proto
dragon breathing fire and a herd of
centaur like harpooned down the
proto-dragon crash into the ground and
the first thing you get to do is go help
them kill the frodo dragon like how cool
is that who is onara onara is the wild
god of the wind and she's appeared
before as like this big spirit eagle
she's the one who guided the centaur to
the dragon isles many many years ago she
blessed them took their caravan across
and then showed them the planes
how fun at the beginning of this
expansion was exploring the culture of
the centaur the centaur are these mighty
awesome hunters that back when they
first came to the dragon isles they
fought the green dragons all day long
eventually they realized that we're
strong you're a strong maybe we should
stop decimating each other's people um
we'll make peace we'll make an agreement
you guys hang out in the groves and the
centaur will hang out in the plains but
now the dragons have been gone for 10
000 years and the centaur have come so
far since then
and they've been here and they've been
existing and developing their culture
they all came over as one clan led by
the mighty maruk and tira and they
founded a new life here
so if you want to get across you have to
follow their rules and their traditions
you have to earn their trust you are the
first outsiders to come in generations
upon generations the centaur might rule
the open plains but the green dragons
make their home in the groves and those
groves are absolutely gorgeous
and how great a job it is that we have
where i can take all of this beautiful
artwork and build these beautiful
fantasy groves high fantasy
we want to do lots of things with an
open plane and we want to be creative
with that but we're restraining
ourselves by letting the zone sing
letting the horizon tell the story we
certainly couldn't have done that in the
vanilla wow no definitely not the zones
are so big and you can see so far
especially in onaran plains so we talked
to the engineers and we actually
increased that distance
it spurs you on to want to adventure and
look through the zone and explore
everything the interesting thing for me
is we have all these conflicts with the
dragon flights there's missing dragons
there's battles there's so much crazy
stuff happening but that's not really
all we're doing there's so much extra
fun activities for people to do and the
greatest thing is that you need to
figure out exactly what's going on and
help solve all the problems that are
just sprouting up everywhere we're just
really excited to tell a story that's
grounded in azeroth and exploration
there's so much more to talk about but
now we're gonna have some folks talking
about the next two zones that players
are gonna experience in the dragon isles
[Music]
hello everyone my name is kate i'm
christy i'm kate i'm shawn we're going
to talk today about that drastics in the
azure span so azure span is going to be
the third zone that players adventure
through and it's one of our biggest
zones that we've done in the dragon
flight maybe even to date we knew it was
going to be like the largest visual
elevation change and it really started
with this great concept art when we
first were taking a look at the design
we kept coming back to one of our
favorite wrath zones which was grizzly
hills and we really wanted to take that
but wowify it more and i don't know if
you've ever been up to the bay area but
in the morning that coastal fog comes in
and dips down into the redwoods and that
sun shines through that's really what we
wanted to encapsulate with this forest
and not only we have redwoods we've got
all different types of trees eventually
it'll break open into this wide open
tundra that's just golden and red and
you'll reach up to another level of
elevation where you get to see the snow
the majority of the zone is covered in
snow and ice we have giant frozen
waterfalls ice rivers as far as the eye
can see and sean i know in the forest we
can expect our first creatures we have a
small group that lives there called the
knolls these knolls are all throughout
the forest and azure span they've made
this their home some nulls with strange
magic that we're going to find out what
exactly that's about snow knolls or as i
call them the snows
up in the winter area and then some
regular knolls that are just going to be
around the forest area so then we go
into the big open tundra where we meet
our second group the tuscar it's gonna
be really neat to explore their culture
a lot more and those kids are adorable i
absolutely love the tuscar honestly all
my down time is probably me hanging out
with the tuscar
so it's been a little while since you've
seen them we remember the tuscara from
wrath of the lich king they're also
getting a nice cool uprise for their
models
along with expanding their culture so
there are going to be male tuscar female
tuscar tuscar kids so we're going to
fight alongside them which includes help
from a certain group of dragons the blue
dragons we're going to follow the story
of kalagos our blue dragon buddy from
the kieran tour and he's going to be
adventuring into cinderella's archives
it's a giant zone there's a lot of
surprises when we're done there we head
over to al drouse's all dresses it's
really incredible because you will be
going through some of the previous zones
and seeing a lot of ruins uh for the
dragon buildings but when you get to
thal drazis everything is perfectly
intact it's beautiful it's pristine it
is the seat of power for all five dragon
flights and home of the dragons
it feels that way with the huge vertical
mountains we've got these great cave
systems where you may end up finding
little dragon hordes my favorite
dragonflight right now is the bronze
they've got a really cool area in
baldraza's and their magic is time
there's so many cool story hooks that we
could dig into there there's so many
cool gameplay options and we have a
little bit of an adventure for players
it's gonna be a lot of fun i can't wait
we really wanted it to feel like their
old stomping grounds one of the really
cool features is going to be the main
city and player hub for this expansion
val draken it is a culmination of all of
the dragon's efforts to put together
what a city would look like so we ended
up having a bunch of really fun small
vignettes where you will see that the
blue dragon flight is hosting a public
library and the red and green dragon of
flights both have their own separate
gardens we'll also have some convenience
services for players including an
auction house in the city which will be
really nice if you're looking for more
exotic wares
the thing that really sold me on with
aldrazis was the initial concept art we
got of tear hole oh yeah wow and this is
a 10 000 year old titan technological
marvel
tear hold has these awesome aqueducts
that actually come out from the
structure all the way to the city across
the valley and in the cinematic there's
just this amazing shot where you see
alexstrasza swoop under one of them and
there's splashes of water cresting
across her wings so when players are
flying around themselves they get to
have their alexstrasza moment what an
incredible place and filled with so much
history
tierhold was built by tyr he was a titan
keeper back in the day who helped the
aspects fight galacron and when they
settled on the dragon isles he built
this facility and even though tears gone
the dragons have held him in reverence
but that was 10 000 years ago and
they've let the titans maintain the
place an incredible amount of history
has happened since then flights have
been nearly wiped out there have been
invasions betrayals aspects have died
and these are the kind of things that
leave marks on a society so now they're
all back here and they're all here
together as we were designing the zone
and the city itself we're trying to
figure out you know how do we tell those
stories at the same time as making sure
that this is a really convenient place
for players to go and go shopping is
what they tend to do so much adventuring
happening on the dragon isles it's so
cool
as a player you probably don't have your
own dragon wings you are going to learn
the art of dragon riding it's so
vertical and i'm just excited to like
dive off the tops of towers and swoop
under things it's actually one of the
things that we're about to learn about
next
hi i'm jake i'm andy i'm kali and i'm
graham and i'm really excited to talk to
you guys today about the drag theory
voker our new race and class coming in
dragon flight we're here to talk about
not only the evoker but also dragon
riding which is our exciting expression
into the exploration of the dragon isles
we knew with a dragon themed expansion
we wanted to let you play a dragon not a
big dragon alexstrasza size that'd be
tough to fit into raids i'm sorry jake i
know i know
but a draconic humanoid so the drag fear
created by neltharion and like our other
hero classes you get to choose if you
want to start on the horde or alliance
side on character creation so let's talk
a little bit about the evoker the class
they can be
what's unique about it is because the
the drag fear are created by an aspect
they have the ability to wield the magic
of all five dragon flights so evokers
can take advantage of red magic and blue
magic and bronze magic and to show that
we created a visual what we call a
prismatic effect this prismatic effect
is basically the coalescence of all
their energy as they channel it into
whatever spell that they're going to
cast you have a red magic spell called
pyre so when you shoot it out of your
mouth it twirls in the air with all five
of the dragonflight's magic as it turns
into the red spell before landing on
your enemies and exploding and hopefully
burning them i'll take that one
getting that vibe across that they use
all five was really important to us but
we did want to make sure that each
specialization focused on two because
casting five different colors gets a bit
messy so their damage dealer
specialization their first of two
devastation mostly focuses on red and
blue magic red being very fast and
explosive burning everything with pyre
whereas blue is more focused and
overwhelming you can shoot a beam of
energy out of your mouth to disintegrate
one single enemy in front of you there's
a healer spec called preservation the
healer spec is going to focus mostly on
your green and your bronze magic so your
green is gonna be evocative of the
emerald dream your growth and your
nurturing spells and then you have your
bronze magic which is gonna be more tiny
whiny so you get to heal a wound faster
so in addition to the visuals and the
animation which will make you feel very
powerful we really want the player to
have a physical connection to the cast
we have a new type of spell called
empower where when you actually hold
down the button on your keyboard it
charges up a spell the longer you charge
it up it might do more damage or hit
more targets depending on
the battlefield and cast while you're
flying raining fire and death from above
it's great
in addition to the gameplay though
another part of feeling draconic is
looking like a dragon well we talk about
dragons breathing fire but you know
what's actually fire what's actually
these customizations
but no they're really really they're
awesome because you have both your
draconic form and your humanoid form and
the customization options for both of
them are amazing they're very good what
about color just tell me tell us about
the color color
you can do a lot of matching so your
visage form can have scales that are the
same color as your dark ear form but my
favorite super favorite part of
customization for the visage form
hair
yeah
because i can actually do this in games
yeah the tech is here
as players make their way through each
of the areas of the dragon isles they'll
partner up with the dragonflights to
move through the air as they've never
done before you'll notice i did not say
flying because flight has a very
specific meaning for world of warcraft
and and we're talking about something
new
called dragon riding
and as the players are honing their
dragon riding skills they're going to
get to see all new animations that go
along with the different look and feel
of the drakes we're aiming to shake up
movement with this new system providing
players with a deeper immersion with
forces like momentum and gravity we knew
that for dragonflight we're going to
have the opportunity to show players a
whole new set of dragon isle drakes
completely unique from all the other
things they've seen in world of warcraft
and so we want to come up with a
movement system that would add that
sense of physics weight and gravity like
you were mentioning we knew it was going
to take a huge team effort not just
animation but it was going to take
effects it was going to take the
engineering team who
we rely on heavily and that combined
with some new animations
really helps to lend that feeling of
physics as you move through the air in
ways that you haven't before and the
icing on the cake is going to be some
really cool effects that we've added on
top of all of that so for example when
you start hitting you know maximum
velocity you're going to see contrails
coming off the edges of the wings
and then as you do your rolls and
spirals you build up more and more speed
there's going to be some screen effects
on the display to indicate that you're
reaching maximum velocity which really
adds to the overall kind of immersion
and sense of reality
as players make their way through the
dragon isles they'll discover new
cosmetic options to fine-tune their
dragon isle drake's appearances
things like snoots horns tails elusive
dragon isle drake armor and more can i
have spikes
definitely okay we want to provide
players with all new skills to play with
as those who can use their momentum well
can reach higher and higher heights and
bring on new more difficult challenges
we just have so many new gorgeous
options to choose from and
i'm just so excited for all of them i'm
excited for the whole thing i mean it's
been a lot of fun to work on but i can't
wait to actually get in the game play it
with you guys i can't wait i can't wait
to fly around dragon isles it's gonna be
great next up you're going to hear about
the talent revamp and the ui changes
coming in dragonflight
[Music]
hello my name is brian i'm crash i'm jay
and i'm laura we are very excited to
share finally revamping the wow hud ui
and it is also time for a major revamp
to talents and specializations i have a
big question for the group how long do
you think it took for us to finally
revamp the wow hud my guess is like 15
years
close 18 years 18 18 years wow you know
technology has changed a lot since we
made the ui back in 2004. now you have
like bigger monitors and us we have
better dev tools to work with so it
makes sense to have the revamp right now
also if you look at the game today the
art evolved beautifully over the years
and if you look at the hud the hud looks
like it got frozen time so when we
approached this we wanted to create a
layout experience that players could
customize move things around adjust it
to fit their needs add-ons today they do
a lot for player customization the
downside is is that not everybody uses
them it's about time that everybody has
the opportunity to use them that they
become a part of the base ui yeah and we
are working very closely with our user
research team to make sure we are
hitting the goals their player needs it
allowed us to add new functionality to
improve accessibility in a lot of areas
and on top of that we are going to be
improving the art yeah so the art update
is a big part of this project the ui
that we have today has a lot of charm
and personality and players have been
using that for 18 years so
with that in mind we want to respect the
players who really like the current ui
but do it more than take to it removing
the clutter and giving more visibility
for your gameplay so the new mini map it
looks bigger and the half bar is also
much bigger if you look at the action
bars and the bottom menus they have less
head frames and
you can really open up your gameplay so
you don't have a lot of ui in front of
you and of course we want to find iconic
pieces from the current hud but we want
to bring it back in a nice way so we for
sure are updating the griffins they look
so nice now and the horde don't worry we
got you you're going to have your
version as well so let's talk about the
edit mode we are putting a mode in that
will let players move
various hud elements around on the
screen so i'm able to move the minimap
say from the right corner all the way
over to the left corner if i want to
bring my action bars from the bottom and
kind of put them more in the center by
my character those are all things that
i'll be able to do absolutely and each
of those different components will have
various sets of options that you'll be
able to work with they'll be able to
save it edit it copy it name it also
it'll remember which spec you're in so
if you're someone who jumps around a lot
as you switch it will switch to whatever
hud layout you have for that spec this
is an ongoing project we're going to
keep working on it so
we really want to hear back from you a
project that we're all excited about
that we've been collaborating a lot on
is something that's pretty ui intensive
and that's the talent system it hadn't
changed in a long time like you said
before and we really started with how
can we have players have more choice
over what their character has as you
level up we give you a new spell or a
new ability something that kind of makes
you stronger but it's it's determined by
the designers we decide the order yeah
we started looking for a system that
would give players a much wider set of
options and after looking at all those
things what we really returned back to
was the idea of trees but it's actually
two trees we have a classroom that offer
different class utility and then we have
a spec tree that is focused on
performing your role whether that's
damage tank or healing can i just jump
in and say that i personally am super
excited about having trees come back
there's a big nostalgia hit for me as we
said we have these two trees because we
feel like picking a specialization is a
really important part of your world of
warcraft character now and so we want to
make sure that when you choose that it
kind of affects the tree in some way
yeah as soon as you open your talent
tree you'll see something new the class
side will have some abilities filled out
for free just kind of starting you off
in that spec you've chosen but then
you'll have your first point to spend in
the class tree which could be something
related to that spec or roll or it could
be something from elsewhere in the class
there's a lot of things that we can do
here and part of that is encouraging
players to perhaps make combinations
that they've never really been able to
see in the game before this is an
opportunity to put a lot more art and
fantasy in the actual talent ui itself
you have seen that a lot through most
recent expansions but not the base ui we
want you to be able to tinker with it
you know we want you to be able to make
a lot of changes at a lot of times and
not necessarily have to commit the power
really is coming back to the player it's
not something we want people to feel
locked into and so one of the things
that we'll be preserving is the ability
to change these talents uh it's the same
kind of frequency that you do now yeah
the old-school players when you see
trees this time just think yeah i'll go
from my raid night to my arena match and
figure out what i think is the best for
both of us and that's a process we want
to make really fluid so we're building a
save load feature that lets you create
your build name it save it and then load
it up very quickly and freely talents
were really about the breadth of options
we've made all these different cool
things over the years but when are they
at their coolest it's when players can
hold the building blocks of what can
make up their class their spec and put
them together in a way that works for
them so these are really cool features
that we've been working long and hard on
and we're very excited about them and
it's just an early preview of the things
we've been doing we can't wait to see
the reaction that you have to them and
please reach out to us and let us know
your thoughts on them and next up we're
going to talk about professions in
dragonflight
[Music]
hi i'm joanna and i'm eric and we're
going to talk about our plans for
professions in dragon flight professions
have been a staple of world of warcraft
forever and they've seen lots of really
cool incremental update over their life
but for dragonflight we want to do
something a bit different we really want
to rethink professions and figure out
how to make them part of your identity
as a player if that's what you want we
really want to make sure that
professions feel fun and relevant across
all levels of game play that brings us
to our first update something that we're
calling crafting orders
if you want to have something crafted
for you but you don't have the skill or
the right profession to do it for
yourself you can have it crafted through
a crafting order
you can basically browse any of the
recipes that can be crafted pick the one
you want for yourself and then you
include some or all of the reagents
needed for the recipe including ones
that only you can get your hands on you
can find someone in person to do it
right in front of you for you or you can
also go to an npc and using an auction
house like interface send the order out
if you're doing this you can pick do you
want to send the order to anyone sort of
a public order or do you want to only
send it to your guild or to a specific
other player maybe it's a friend who you
know will be able to craft the item
really well for you if you are really
dedicated to your craft you're gonna be
the best at what you do one of the
coolest things about this is the item
you had crafted can also be soul bound
in the past you could only get your
hands on crafted soulbound items by
having that profession yourself now
anyone can have them crafted for them
which is really neat and really expands
the number of items that we can provide
that are really powerful because
everyone can have them crafted through
the crafting owner system this is also
really cool because it means as a
crafter you can start building your
client base people are going to come
back to you to get certain items maybe
you're the best at making it or you
always throw in a little something extra
you're also going to be leveling up your
profession it's going to be really great
so the first time you go to craft you're
going to notice a lot of different
things but probably the biggest is the
introduction of quality both to your
crafted items and your gathered reagents
quality works in a pretty simple way if
you craft something that's a higher
quality it's just going to be better for
a piece of gear that probably means a
higher item level if it's for instance a
potion that might mean a more powerful
effect at a higher quality and we're
doing a lot of new things in the ui
we've put a lot of work into it to make
sure that the professions feel
really special and unique and another
thing you might notice in the crafting
ui that's new is the introduction of
stats specifically to your professions
both crafting and gathering and this is
another sort of major input into
quality probably the biggest source of
your ability to craft items at a higher
quality is through crafting
specializations we've had crafting
specializations in the past as far back
as original world of warcraft with
dragonflight you can go out and earn
specialization points in a whole bunch
of different ways so maybe you find an
old book on a bookshelf in a ruin
somewhere or a hermit in a cave who can
teach you a little bit about your
profession so let's say you're a
blacksmith
and you might decide that first you want
to become an armored smith and the more
points you spend in armorsmithing the
better you're going to get at crafting
all armor this also means that if you
specialize one way other people in your
guild may specialize in a completely
different path so this means that your
guild could have several top blacksmiths
and everybody's providing something
unique and valuable to the team which is
really cool now that reminds me of
another update we're actually adding
crafting tables to all the different
crafting professions we're going to take
those we're going to put them all in the
main city of valdrakin and you're gonna
go in there and you're gonna get to see
all the different players crafting their
items at their cool crafting tables yeah
it means you're gonna walk into the city
and you're gonna see like all these
alchemists huddled over here and you're
gonna see all these blacksmiths over by
the forge there will be other players
filling orders or grabbing orders
there's gonna be a whole new crafting
area that's gonna make you feel really
part of the world it just seems like a
much more lively area than it has in the
past what i'm most excited about though
is the gear we're introducing new types
of gear for every profession and when
you go to say mine and node you're
actually going to just switch into that
gear it's going to be really great
you're not going to have to carry that
stuff around in your backpack anymore
it's actually going to be dedicated
slots for each each of your pieces of
gear but i'm a numbers guy i love
progressing all pieces of profession
gear will have those special stats that
we mentioned before on them and as you
get your hands on better versions of the
gear you know it's really going to help
you get better at your profession i
can't wait thank you for tuning in to
the dragonflight deep dive you've heard
a lot about the content and changes
coming in dragonflight and we've got a
lot more in store for you in the coming
months until then we'll see you in
azeroth
[Music]
you